>> Laura: THE LATEST IN THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION, THE FISA
MEMO RELEASED BY HOUSE INTEL
DEMOCRATS OVER THE WEEKEND HAS
SOME KEY DIFFERENCES FROM THE
ONE RELEASED A FEW WEEKS AGO BY
THE REPUBLICANS.
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY FISA WARRANT
MADE ONLY NARROW USE OF THAT
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER, AND
REPUBLICANS CLAIM THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN NO WARRANT WITHOUT IT.
THE TWO SITES ALSO DISAGREE
WHETHER THE FBI INFORMED THE
COURT OF THE POLITICAL ORIGINS
OF THE DOCUMENT WHICH IS PAID
FOR BY THE DNC AND THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
WHO IS TELLING THE TRUTH?
THAT'S DEBATED WITH A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN, MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, AND THE
FORMER ADVISOR TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE HILLARY CLINTON.
DON'T LAUGH.
>> DIFFERENT PRONUNCIATION
THERE.
>> Laura: I LIKE TO KEEP YOU
GUESSING.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE KIND OF
CELEBRATING OVER THE WEEKEND,
THEY SAY, IT REALLY WASN'T THE
REASON THE EXPRESSION
INVESTIGATION BEGAN, THEY WERE
SURVEILLING CARTER PAGE FOR SOME
TIME, THEN THIS INFORMATION CAME
UP IN THE SUMMER OF 2016.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE, YOU KNOW,
MAKING A MOUNTAIN OUT OF A MOLE
HILL.
>> IT'S FASCINATING, LAURA,
WHAT'S NOT IN THE DEMOCRATIC
MEMO.
THE FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE, THE
CASH OF THE COMMITTEE WAS INTO A
WARRANT DESPITE AMERICAN
CITIZENS, AND SURPRISINGLY, THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO DOES NOT SAY
HILLARY CLINTON'S NAME ONCE AND
IT DOESN'T MENTIONED THE DNC
WANTS.
I THINK IT IS INTERESTING THAT A
LOT OF THE REPUBLICAN CLAIMS
THAT ARE BOLSTERED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO INCLUDING THE
FACT THAT THE DOSSIER WAS USED
TO GET THIS WARRANT AND THAT A
YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE PLANTED BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS ALSO
SERVED AS A VALID BASIS FOR
THIS.
>> IT'S SHAMEFUL.
>> I HAVE LEARNED THAT IF I'M
GOING TO PLAY POKER WITH
SOMEONE, THEREFORE, WANT TO PLAY
WITH, DONALD TRUMP, CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ, JIM JORDAN -- YOU
STARTED -- AND DEVIN NUNES.
THESE GUYS WHERE THEIR FEAR ON
THEIR SLEEVES.
WHEN THEY YELL "MEMO," WHEN THE
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION, IT MEANS
THEY KNOW WHAT IS COMING.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE A HEADS UP,
BUT THEY KNOW THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
IN THIS CASE, IN THE PREVIOUS
CASE, WHEN YOU CALLED FOR THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL MOLAR TO BE
FIRED -- SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER
TO BE FIRED, HE WAS APPOINTED IN
MAY, AT SIX MONTHS GO BY, WHY DO
YOU WAIT?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY, FIVE DAYS
BEFORE HIS LEGISLATION,
PAUL MANAFORT WAS INDICTED.
FIVE DAYS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATION, THE INDICTMENT, MY
CLAIM IS RUMORED TO BE TALKING
TO MUELLER.
>> Laura: THE SAME ONE THAT
COMEY SAID DIDN'T MIND.
>> WE SEE LEGISLATION COMING OUT
OF THE SKY WHEN THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING
DONALD TRUMP'S BIDDING.
>> WILL PLAY POKER ANY TIME, BUT
WE HOLD THE ACES IN THAT GAME
WHEN YOU GOT A CIRCUMSTANCE WHEE
MUELLER'S TEAM HAS
STRONG EVIDENCE OF BIAS AND
STILL TO THIS DAY NOT A SINGLE
PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT THERE WAS
ANY COLLUSION.
WHEN YOU GUYS LOST THIS
CAMPAIGN, YOU HAD TO BLAME THE
RUSSIANS, YOU HAD TO BLAME
BERNIE SANDERS.
AT ONE POINT, YOU GUYS PLAY
THEM.
YOU JUST HAD A WORSE CANDIDATE.
>> Laura: GUYS --
>> AT 1.. DO YOU SAY, I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING
IN OUR ELECTION?
>> I AM CONCERNED ABOUT RUSSIA
MEDDLING IN ELECTIONS ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
BUT YOU GUYS --
>> YOU TOOK AN OATH TO --
>> Laura: WHAT DID OBAMA --
WHAT DID OBAMA --
>> WHY DO YOU ALLOW RUSSIA --
>> IT GOT SO BAD THAT YOU GOT
BEAT BY 100 RUSSIAN TROLLS?
YOU WERE SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY DAY AND YOU THINK
RUSSIAN TROLLS --
>> REPUBLICANS SAY THAT --
>> Laura: LETS THE DEMOCRATS
FINALLY CAME AT THE RUSSIANS.
LAST TIME I CHECKED THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO THE RESET AND THE
BUTTON, AND WE WERE SMILING AT
CONFERENCES AND SO FORTH.
CARTER PAGE, OBVIOUSLY THE
TARGET OF THE SURVEILLANCE, I
INTERVIEWED HIM A FEW WEEKS
BACK.
I ASKED HIM SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THIS GUY WHO IS MENTIONED IN THE
DEMOCRAT'S MEMO, SOMEONE THE
STEELE DOSSIER CLAIMS HE MET
WITH, ASKED HIM ABOUT THIS
INDIVIDUAL.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I GAVE A SPEECH, AND THERE
WAS ONE SEEDIER GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL WHO SPOKE AFTER ME, HE
WAS WALKING OUT OF THE BUILDING
AFTER HE GAVE HIS SPEECH, AND WE
HAD A VERY BRIEF CONVERSATION
FOR LESS THAN 10 SECONDS.
>> WAS THAT IGOR DIVEYKIN?
>> NO, I HAVE NEVER MET
DIVEYKIN.
>> Laura: USA AND YOU'VE NEVER
MET IGOR DIVEYKIN?
>> I'VE NEVER MET HIM IN MY
LIFE.
>> IN THE SPIRIT OF
BIPARTISAN -- I THINK WE CAN SAY
THAT HE IS THE DUMBEST PERSON IN
THIS SCANDAL.
>> THAT IS THE CHARACTERISTIC OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO --
>> BUT HE IS THE BASIS, HIS TRIP
AND HIS WORK GOING BACK, THE
BASIS.
>> Laura: YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
AND THE FACT THAT IN THE END,
THIS MEMO, THE FISA WARRANT DID
NOT INCLUDE THAT?
REAL QUICK, I'M GOING TO GO
BLACK.
>> IT SAID THAT IT CAME FROM --
>> IT WOULDN'T HAVE BOTHERED
YOU?
IT WOULD HAVE BOTHERED ME.
>> FRIENDS DON'T GIVE THE FBI
INFORMATION ON FRIENDS.
>> YOU WOULDN'T HAVE LIKED THAT.
>> WOULD BE THE TARGET BECAUSE I
DIDN'T ALLUDE.
>> Laura: ONE LOOK AT CARTER.
GUYS, GUYS, GUYS, HE CAN'T BE
BOTH DUMB AND KIND OF DOING THIS
SUPERSECRET SPY NETWORK.
>> SURE, HE CAN BE A BAD SPY.